all right so this is the vault what was
this one fascinating like this one was
like I really dug this one um pretty
good it answered a good chunk of
question like a lot really and it did it
something about the way they answered it
it was very natural I didn't feel it
didn't feel urgent like a lot of
episodes where they answer a lot of
stuff there's like this extreme urgency
and it's like really dramatic and really
dark and intense which is fine but it's
nice to have one where it's just sort of
very I don't know it's a little bit more
laid-back and it just sort of lets
things very naturally explain itself um
I mean it felt to me like a campfire
story yeah a little bit or I mean really
what it is you know just sort of like a
pass you know a past life experience
like just something like yes sir I have
like a feeling that this gonna happen
but you don't know whatever I don't know
I read past life experience I just
assume that's what they're like um all
the time I have a past life I hear
jewelry laughs sometimes you know you're
full of your head dude oh my head okay I
already got over her she's dead I'm
already looking for someone new I got
over her that wasn't strange imaginary
hand hitting me from out of nowhere he
hurt maybe your cast lights attacking
you possibly trying to tell you
something anyway so all right so Finn
has what it actually now was it a dream
in the opening I'm trying to think now
like Alabama is something's attacking
him that seems to be in his mind you
know
you remember her at least yes we see her
a couple times right
yeah no cuz I remember that big blobby
thing so she comes back you know she's
got the green air and everything and
she's trying to get his attention trying
to attack him and Finn acknowledges that
I've liked her the vault which I think
they've also referenced before that
right and they put your person might
have her they do that as well it's like
cuz he sees her in Jake's like what are
you talking about huh you're just crazy
it's like uh no one's going into the
vault and it's go yeah yeah so so I read
this I like that they actually I
like that the vaults kind of comes back
it's just it's so literal and I like how
I like how he very much acknowledges
that it's there and it's probably for
his own good and just serve like this
repression is fine you know and it's
it's sometimes you can see how someone
can get that mindset it's like you know
no I know this is gonna make me
miserable nothing Goods gonna come in so
I'm just gonna a recent you know but but
I like this too because it shows that
those things can come back and you can
you know help yourself from it and stuff
so so so this girl's attacking him that
the giant slug ghost girl whatever that
was that we see in the past and Jake
Watson to acknowledge what it is so sets
up this hypnosis video inside BMO that
has him go to a past life and bus ish I
forgot her name was it
sudowoodo how do you say vehicle you oh
wow God so I've been practicing your
voice and you know throwing my voice
yeah those you didn't even have your
mouth yeah let me see the name again
ready choko choko okay that's impressive
i like sudowoodo better yeah but you
said show go so yeah um sorry so so this
girl named shoka is one arm lifts in a
past life or you know just at least in
the past you know because we see
bubblegum is there and she's putting the
chain guards together and Shoko gets
this quest from whoever the hell that
guy was just this guy who likes to wear
a those boys yeah the bad bounce boys
that's right and just likes to be in a
bath and tells her to get this amulet
from Mitch my fingers tonight yes I give
this amulet from bubblegum hey my bad
and so she goes it sort of forms this
nice friendship with bubblegum and
bubblegum gives her another arm but very
much like the arm that Finn had before
in what's that tend to clean over life
where he went - yeah so which one the
one with the
pretty boring really letdown yeah don't
forget a pool boy uh that's why they did
the other arm yeah got it it's really
fascinating okay so that's why I really
liked this episode serve all these
things it's like yeah ha that's like
these things keep coming back you're
realizing they're coming back more and
more the oh it's not like just a
one-time thing it's like none of these
sort of images and things like they're
they're coming back and so it forms of
friendship with her but she still still
see it still steals the amulet and gets
tossed into the green river which does
she jumps she's trying to get away the
gumball guardian's shoots and kind of
knocks her into it it's an accident yes
so so she eventually crawls out is the
big glob whatever says you know oh cool
I have another arm shame it's when you
have to sit my what is it when my reset
button is being poised her sound like I
hit my reset button yeah I love that
turns a great serve and Finn finally
wakes up realizes what he has to do he
goes to where the body is which I guess
is under under his house or in the or in
the tree no that's high cuz she's around
the tree is that so she grew that's
really cool like I said this episode
just felt very natural and I like that
so um so and he grabs the pea omelet and
gives it back to bubblegum and he's like
women you're like super super old you're
not you know 19 what the hell you
talking about it she just sort of hung
as it goes teehee and I think I think
it's where it is it was there well it's
like the last line cuz there she smiles
and then was he just say it's cool or
something I can't remember oh my god you
like totally blanked my brain I know
that like you're Rizzo a lot but you
hopefully wasn't then but now watch I go
the fancy gummy like it was the melting
point line this year
I think so but yeah I I like stuff about
I like stories about past life I just
think they're interesting I like stuff
about like you know how much is are you
in control of and how much is sort of
like your past history or whatever past
life or genetics or whatever and this
art has fun with that not only with like
the arm I mean like you said before
we've seen that twice now more than that
Oh even more yeah okay so it's popped up
a lot and we clearly see one now where
she she does not have an arm we know how
she lost the arm but but her design also
seems very much like a mix between you
know Finn but also the in the Finn the
human episode it seemed very much like
you know the eyes that she has were very
much like what Finn had in that episode
and even sort of the rest of her layout
it just sort of seemed like a mix
between those two so I thought was very
interesting why so because that's the
first thing I thought to my head no my
so she didn't have an arm I'm like
that's interesting then the robot arm
comes back you know like almost the
exact same design thing this the what's
that the same design was a little
different I think it's a little bit
different but pretty much the same yeah
it's plug and play so I don't see now
cuz they've never talked about the idea
of like past lives in this so you corns
you started doing you really think it
can exist I mean at least not in this
way where it's like you die you come
back as somebody else you die you
reincarnation Italy yeah cuz shaman give
us a comet here's the butterfly give us
some things that shape yeah thing and
then they get hurt yeah um so it it just
explains so much again because you get
the relationship between sort of him a
bubblegum now in a sense more like why
he would be sort of attracted to her
because it's like or at least just
something bullying tool towards her
because they had a connection before
yeah you know that there was this
connection and like I said the fact that
this arm somehow Anto it's the same arm
right
it's always stuck down somehow that
keeps coming back in the play I don't
know when you have when you have like
past lives and reincarnation there's
just this sense of why you can do so
much with that like what else are they
gonna do with this yeah
because you don't know how much was sort
of predestined and how much is being
made up on the fly and it's I don't know
it's like that it's like you think what
other sort of cool direction can they go
in this show that like really opens up
these possibilities because it's so
friggin weird and out there you can't
think well they serve done it all but
that really opens up a lot of
possibilities um you know they sort of
already done other realities of stuff
but they haven't not quite like this
they haven't done a past life and yeah
man it's just you can really do so much
you can just do so much more with that
than just cutting to a flashback like
yeah but stuff of Marceline Ice King you
know it is great and it's very effective
but you can't get the idea okay it's
always gonna be this it's gonna be a
flashback or just magic make you forget
something something about having a past
life like I said it just creates this
history and this connection in a way
that now those other things can so I'm
really fascinated by then I really like
this episode a lot and I think it was
really nicely done
Bri brought up some things I liked and
ideas I thought of Bri what were they
again green banana guys because I'm not
right the I did not notice that you
didn't know some with the horn
no oh yeah I missed it which goes back
all to what I was gonna say I didn't
remember that one very first episode
it's like oh oh mr. creampuff we used to
date oh okay yeah I totally forgot about
that that's interesting
all right well let's it was Cinnabon or
mr. Stinson to me bun was cinnamon bun
in there or no I didn't see it at least
okay I mean oh sorry I'm throwing my
voice again yeah No
yeah yeah but it's it just say maybe
your baby okay
demonic arts yet yes no I liked it I
thought it was a nice again kind of like
pulling on past episodes finally in a
sense wrapping up the whole ghost girl
continually appearing now her design and
I could just be because of my daughter
reminded me of home stuck the eyes even
the mouth and the teeth the lack of the
nose everything just kind of looked like
Homestuck to me
now let's clarify Homestuck because she
reads a lot of homeless dog not because
she looks like a character from no no no
no Briony no real except character form
stuff okay
I don't read Homestuck so I'm not sure
now what everyone's gonna be like here's
the big dogs that get crackin cuz not
like I haven't had enough people tell me
that all right anyway know that Mike saw
her the first time that's like the first
thing that popped in my head was God she
looks like someone from Homestuck but
then again that's just me there may be a
reference there there may not I have no
idea I've you loved the arm that's
always fun to see when he she has a new
arm or has no arm I did love the fact
that the building if you look it's like
chunks of like chocolate or cake it's
probably cake but I like that the whole
oh we have to cover up this lake of
toxic waste with candy I love just
finally seeing where the gumball
guardian's actually came from because
when I first saw them in the first
episode I was taking it they were like
magical and then the one episode where
you see one of the heads in the basement
I'm like what the heck is that I know
you see that they're actually just
created by bubblegum bubblegum is that
good yeah I always sort of felt like
maybe they were like at a lien I've
explained it just something it's like
almost mythical like they've been there
for eons and eons
yeah but I don't mind them I don't mind
them being you know maybe by girl you
know I really needs like because I was
always curious where that came from
I did like how she when I'm trying to
remember what her name was again what
was the girl's name again sometimes your
other voice remember yeah it's weird and
it sounds like you laugh or two also so
oh yeah for the whole double bulk record
thing yeah no that's really impressive
yes I'm good um but no I love when she's
like oh yeah boa blonde it's never
excuse a good computer Bubblegum's like
what yeah they gave my arm for a
computer what is wrong with your parents
and then later on they dropped me out of
the dojo never came back but that's
another running theme bad parents Flame
Princess Marceline Finn even to an
extent Joshua he wasn't the best parents
who you know Finn mm-hmm well even that
we don't really I mean as now we don't
know what happened to Finn's you know
human yeah parents you know so that they
could abandon them probably no but I
mean that's kind of thing that's running
thing is like not the best parents in
the world
mm-hmm and that's kind of free like
solidified shit where the phone's
ringing
so why don't you go after that lay on
yourself that's all you can toss your
voice and you can toss your voice to
answer phones get better believe it that
and I just saw how your voice turned off
the answering machine we're gonna run
this bit toward the octet and
reincarnated just like this episode um
no I really really really really liked
this episode it's a lot of fun seeing
some of the beginnings it was nice
seeing cuz before we got like a view of
what it was like right after the
mushroom war yeah this is I kind of like
left or more this modern times
and I really like it's kind of like a
nice little middle ground yeah it's the
same we don't really we haven't really
seen mm-hmm um and yeah there's like
even while you were talking like three
other things
we're probably my head I'm like yeah
golly that that that too um with uh and
I forgot one of them okay I'll go the
other one um with uh again with
bubblegum it's like now is sort of
telling what I said before with our
character uh it seems like there's a
much more defined character now because
now so much of what she's saying that's
not written funny is made funny because
of what I know about her like you know
there's the scene I think she says your
parents are the worst and I realize like
her personality now very much in
contrast to house you start out is
someone who's you know just everything
is very serious and must be taken very
you know straightforward and yes and
scientific there's no time and stuff but
it still served this very like she's
still gonna try and be a little cheerful
but everything is very adult and very
serious and very you know
straightforward and you know and very
technical in science scientific so I
think lines like that something as
simple as like your parents are the
worst and that could very easily just
come off as you know oh whatever lie you
know anyone can say that yeah yeah
whatever but you know her very
articulate like your parents are the
worst you know now it's there's a very
defined character now um which i think
is great it's not you know because
before she was just just a princess
character it's like oh she's just nice
and bubbly whatever it's like she they
really run a character around her now um
and it's like Alma's are tough enough
well one thing that I find interesting
about bubblegum is and again it's the
whole thing of what my other self would
say it's how PB is kind of you know a
bitch or evil or whatever but like this
one to me kind of again solidifies that
I don't think she's just being a bitch
to be a bitch I think she's cut herself
up emotionally from most of the stuff
that goes on someone she was actually
getting close to falls into this thing
and what's the first thing she says not
oh my god she was stealing from me not
oh my
God you know I can't stand this no quick
get her out of there you know it didn't
she didn't care about the stealing it
was saved this person that I actually
care about and in the end what happens
still couldn't find her so she was like
fine it's kind of like I give up
again I will outlive everyone here I
will be here a lot longer than everyone
else will and I think this is one of
those times where she's finally resigned
herself to that it kind of sucks being
alone yeah I'll have all these people
around me but at the same time they'll
pretty much all die before I will well
and I think if I the guess the way her
characters or I came about is that the
rotor is like just you know sir nice and
bubbly you know they had the science
thing from the very beginning but you
know wasn't necessarily a huge focus
again she was just sort of nice and the
ruler and brilliant stuff like that uh
but over time with that public
personality they found it was funny or
if they sort of would do some variations
like that love that one episode where I
think Oh what was it the nut good guy
you know we rented just what it's saying
like me and insane it was just like
where'd this come from you know it that
it's really funny uh but then the surra
has to be you know define well why what
part of her you know makes her like that
yeah and I or maybe they just thought it
was funnier than when they we keep going
back to that and the syrup became this
character that there is sort of this
really dark heavy burden that she's
carrying to with all of it but the other
thing now uh okay so she's not
whatever nineteen yeah earlier so why
did she say that before why did she lie
about her age what woman doesn't know
okay one thing weird about when when
growing up is it's not polite to ask a
woman her age yes I always ask how much
they weigh dads are okay with sorry
now I think it's more or less one of
those things to put people at ease
especially someone - again lifespans if
someone came up to us in like I don't
know where was like oh I've known you
for you know a couple years now by the
way I'm actually like a thousand years
old well but Marceline is not issue and
Finn even tried to still hang with her
they just met bubblegum and Finn have
known each other a little bit longer
okay Marceline kind of met it was just
like yo I'm this old deal with it but
well hey you seem to be fine I mean I
guess I don't maybe keeping up
appearances and stuff for everyone else
whatever but my phone advertising
something you said before about being
alone and that she can't really be with
anyone so it's like buff in still a kid
so the argument I'm 19 or whatever you
know is a legit argument for this is why
we can't be together but on top of that
it's like she's even older has been
around even longer she's like yeah I
mean but not just physically or whatever
but mentally probably on 19 as well you
know it knows all this stuff so yeah
it's like out of all this oh that's
interesting this new shit as we brought
to light man and you know shit man she
kidnapped herself well yeah look at a
dude she's got to feed the monkey you
know shit man and this is that work yeah
um but yeah yeah it was a good episode
wait you said monkey yeah feeding it I
like monkeys yeah she's probably big
kidnap her so follow those other times
we think that maybe it's just like to
have you know cuz it's like she wouldn't
nowadays I mean like I said she's like
got a bajillion guards all the hacker
stuff doesn't work the more they like
half the people she creates are not very
smart didn't think about how old some of
them are well peppermint Butler's gotta
pee well I guess he's in the demonic art
since
now - it's like I don't like he's so
smart by comparison but but again - I
can't create life so at least not from
candy what I do you know how yeah duh
let me show ya yeah what's it okay
hey dear joy boys again No
I love it